yes but the the UM I think that you know
the Daily Show has always been I think
sort of half about making fun of the
conventions of television news and then
making fun of news events themselves and
the second is sort of time-honored you
know pointing out the disparity between
what a leader says and does and that
that's space that disparity is a sweet
spot where the funny is and that's time
on and that's been around forever and
that's a good thing and then the first
half of it i think is is is the parody
element and making fun of the excesses
of the anchorwoman on MSNBC who's you
know breathless over paris hilton and
then you know spends five minutes on
that and then follows up with 30 seconds
about you know major healthcare crisis
or something like that I don't think
that there's any danger I think that's
worth I think that's worth mocking a lot
I think it's worth I think i think
that's that's worth mocking a lot so if
people become very cynical about
television news coverage I don't think
it's the worst thing in the world I
think if I think if the show decided to
just spray gun fire at everything at
printer at every print journalist as
well uh everything Kerr then every
columnist you know I don't know how
practical that would be and I mean they
would be terrible I guess what I'm
saying is and I haven't thought of this
before but if it means that people watch
a little less cable news and go
elsewhere for their news well that's not
so bad I mean I think I think I mean
ultimately I think like the the the the
when people say oh say is the show or
shows like that making our shows like
that making people lose faith in the
whole process I don't think so I don't
think
politicians wings can be clipped enough
I really don't